What do you do when you're broke in?
What do I do when I'm broken?
When I'm broken,
I relish it. That's what I'm gonna do. I'm going to use it
cause [inaudible].
If I'm broken, then I just found my limitations
and until I know what my limitations are,
how can I push them? How can I get better?
But once, once I see it,
once I feel it, once I see where I was broken,
then I can a cap. That weakness,
I can fill in that gap.
I can reinforce that breach.
If you break, it means it's time to
fortify your wheel to make it stronger.
They look, there's, there's all kinds of different ways to break.
You can break physically, you can break mentally,
you can break your heart,
you can break your spirit and none of those are fun and all of those are going
to leave a mark.
But the mark that they leave can be the mark of victory or it can be the mark of
defeat
because every time you break in, in every way that you break,
wow, it's a chance.
It's definitely a chance for you to give up and for you to just to fall apart.
But there's also opportunity.
There's opportunity to get stronger and get smarter and get faster and get
tougher and get more stable and get more resilient and get
better.
When you break,
you have the opportunity to show the world,
the whole world what you are really made of.
So, so if you break, if, if you break,
yeah,
the fight easing over.
In fact, if you break the fight is just beginning.
And as you crawl up and out of that dismal and wretched place covered,
and you covered in Plod and sweat and dirt and filth,
as you rise above what you were,
and as you take the form of,
of who you are supposed to be,
you will see that in the very act of standing up in the very act of fighting on
you will become a, and you will remain
unbroken.